[Music]
I uh
um
anyway I uh am Dave Ruben and this is
the reubin report it's January 25th 2024
we're live streaming on Rumble locals in
YouTube Share subscribe tap that
notification Bell if you have not
postgame show as always rubben report.
locals.com we're going to cover a bunch
of stuff up top because there is a
massive fight of Bruin between the
federal government and the state of
Texas and I suspect some other states
about to get involved in this thing uh
and then after that we're going to be
doing a Ruben report Community Q&A so if
you want to get a question in on the Fly
while we are live on the computer
machine you can join us Ruben report.
locals.com uh we mentioned yesterday
that the Supreme Court in a 54 ruling uh
with John Roberts and Amy Comey Barrett
siding with the more liberal justices
have decided that Texas cannot protect
its own border I don't have to explain
to you what's been going on for the
months and months now uh under the Biden
Administration where we are seeing
literally at this point hundreds of
thousands of people pour into this
country we have no idea where these
people are coming from we have no idea
what their intentions are we don't know
where they're going etc etc uh and Texas
Greg Abbott over in Texas had finally
decided that he's had enough right the
governor was just like all right you
know what federal government you're not
going to do your thing uh we're going to
go ahead and do it that's what the
Constitution was created for basically
right uh that's also what Federalism is
all about the idea that we are the
United States of America but the states
are supposed to basically control what's
in their borders the federal government
is supposed to control the external
border of the whole country but when the
federal government is either negligent
or downright in der elction of its Duty
the states better step up and now the
Supreme Court has uh warned or ruled
against Texas and uh I want to overstate
it but it sort of feels like all hell is
breaking loose so we're going to cover
all of that and more but first let me
tell you guys about TWC Health guys I've
been talking to you guys about the
wellness company and their medical
emergency kit for quite some time and
their next product is one that I believe
every American should be taking
regularly or at the very least have on
hand for when necessary it's called
Spike support and you're going to want
to listen up if you're not thinking that
something is going on at this point with
so many previously healthy people
experiencing myocarditis blood clots
turboc cancers menstrual irregularities
miscarriages and the new died suddenly
phenomenon you're not paying attention
the culprit is Spike protein Spike
protein is a lingering threat from both
the vaccine and the man-made virus
linked to all kinds of long-term health
issues even fizer is now admitting there
are problems so many people myself
included are looking for answers and
ways to stay healthy despite the SP
despite the spike proteins try to say
that three times fast that are part of
our population now and while we know
those answers won't ever come from
mainstream sources truth seeking doctors
like Dr Peter McCulla Dr Drew Pinsky
who's going to be in studio on Monday
and their team at the wellness company
are here to provide answers in hope
there's one question that these doctors
get asked every single day how do I
detox from the spike protein Left Behind
from the vaccine and covid and thanks to
the wellness company there's actually
something we can do Spike support
formula is a unique blend of natural
ingredients which aim to block and
dissolve Spike protein in your body so
you can get back to that pre-co feeling
and stop waiting for the other shoe to
drop their website has tons of
testimonials of customers report
reporting increased mental Clarity and
energy levels amongst other things
whether they got poked or not reclaim
your health at
twc.com code Ruben in this fight for
truth and medical Freedom you owe it to
yourself and your family to take control
of your health and now back to me okay
so before we fully dive into the Border
situation which
is it's hot right now to say the least
and and it's so unfortunate because we
did not have to be in this place we did
not have to be in a place where the
Supreme Court would now be issuing
rulings against the states we did not
have to be in a place where Texas would
now be fighting with this Administration
there have been plenty of warning signs
for months and months plenty of people
not just me have been showing you these
videos we now know that even on the
Democrat side of the aisle that their
base is going okay maybe something
something's a little wrong with having
all of these people come in right like
having our homeless shelters overrun
with migrants maybe that's a bit of a
problem the crime the violence all of
that stuff so before we get to that I
want to give you a backdrop on it
because one of the only ways that this
issue has bubbled up is because of
online media because the mainstream
media is is slow motion what do I always
say truth is a Time release pill they
get to everything six months later
usually when it's too late and then they
only give you the wrong solutions to the
problem even when they get what the
problem actually is one of the solutions
to all of that was about a year and a
half ago when Elon Musk uh bought
Twitter he bought it for about what was
it 42 Bill something like that 44 Bill
an extra two Bill who knew 44 bill it's
losing money but he bought it and it is
offered the greatest defense of free
speech and our ability to share videos
get a counter narrative out there and
everything else Elon Musk sat down as
you know he went to aitz uh with Ben
Shapiro they then did an interview after
uh and here he is talking a bit about
how he's using Twitter X as it's now
known to expose the Legacy Media
technically there's people on Instagram
with more followers but in terms of of
interactions um I have the most
interacted with social media account on
Earth um think I I think I recently
passed 169 million followers so can 169
million people be
wrong
I know we'll find out in the next
election cycle um but you know when when
when you feel that do you think that
that was a reaction to the fact that you
were basically saying the thing you're
not supposed to say which is that the
sources of information that people are
receiving are in fact siphoned off and
censored yeah exactly
um it was actually amazing to me how
much the Legacy Media
uh you know walks in lock step you know
there's like Nobody Breaks ranks um
so uh now we have X that breaks ranks
and doesn't just go with the whatever
the approved narrative is um I think for
many in the public they don't quite
realize just how much they they you know
deception is really going on with the
media the the biggest deception is the
choice of narrative because they can the
media can say they can write a story
about this or write a story about that
and only only a few stories can go in
the front page so you're deciding
essentially what people should pay
attention to um so instead of it being
something that you know what what people
pay attention to it being what people
actually care about it's actually what a
handful of editors care about they're
telling you telling the people what to
pay attention to so that the deception
by choice of narrative is a big thing so
that's why I really want the narratives
to Bubble Up organically from the people
in the case of the EX system which they
do love that line there deception by
choice of narrative right one of the
things that I wrote about and don't burn
this book is that you know when you talk
about fake news fake news is usually
when people think oh they're just making
up a story or the headline doesn't match
what's actually in the article itself
but the most nefarious type of fake news
is when they do not cover something they
ignore a story so for months and months
and months when mainstream media is not
covering the Border that's a type of
fake news because they are controlling
what the narrative is deception by
choice right that's a that's a really
really interesting concept they're
deciding what people can pay attention
to and you know if for those of you that
are uh let's say Gen X or above uh you
remember when at 6:30 on ABC NBC and CBS
they had their news programs and and
really they covered the about the exact
same stuff almost in the exact same
order it might have been a little bit
different but if you were watching NBC
News at 6:30 with Tom Brokaw and then
you flipped over to CBS News or to ABC
news with Peter Jennings it was
basically the same stuff maybe they
changed which way they were showing it
like okay that's Story number one this
is Story number four but it was
basically the same so the Overton window
stayed the same was sort of like this
and then everybody in the country kind
of believed the same stuff cable news
comes in eventually of course the
internet comes in and now news is
bubbling up from the bottom there are
there are uh Twitter
reporters Robert F Kennedy Jr going to
the Border going uh there's a problem
here Elon Musk going to the Border uh
there's a problem here and the
mainstream media is pissed about that so
this idea of the Overton window what we
are allowed to talk about uh that really
is the issue here Elon had a bit more to
say about that what do you think is the
biggest Untold narrative the thing that
the the media have been missing for for
years and years or suppressing for years
and
years um well there's a few things but
um you know I I I I've generally try to
say like to increase what the so-call
overturn window of what can be discussed
what what you know what what is it okay
to discuss without being
ostracized um suddenly attacking Dei was
you know would have been ostracized
before not and not anymore um and
um you know any anything that's sort
of
sensitive or or that the media ignores
uh the public can then you know raise
the raise it on on the xplatform and and
and make that an actual topic of
discussion what's interesting about sort
of Citizen journalism or it's not even
it's not even journalism what's
interesting about a guy who wanders down
to a Border Town and just like sees
what's going on and then shares his
thoughts is that it bubbles up from the
bottom and then the people decide oh
that is in boy that's interesting why
wasn't that on CNN so this leads us to
the question so what is being discussed
on X Twitter and say on rum and locals
and places like that that is basically
being completely ignored by mainstream
Media or mainstream media is just
getting to it really late right
mainstream media is kind of covering the
Border stuff now because they cannot
ignore it anymore it makes them look
completely complicit and or ridiculous
so of course the the migrant crisis the
illegal immigration crisis is the main
thing check out this video This is Wild
this is from Boston Logan Airport and
they are housing illegals take a
look that's Boston Logan Airport Boston
Logan Airport by the way what was it two
of the planes from 911 I believe
originated at Boston Logan Airport who
are these people what are the security
measures over there is that a hotel is
that a Migrant Center remember when we
showed you months and months ago we
probably on this show showed it to you I
don't know six eight months ago what was
going on at the Texas El Paso Airport
right and that's thought of as a Border
Town so who cares what's going on down
there you ship a couple of those people
up to Martha's Vineyard and then all
hell breaks loose those liberals don't
have to live on their little island with
people of another color that's very
scary for them Barack Obama's got his 30
Acres on the water he's freaking out
over climate change don't put any extra
pressure on him so you understand this
these people come in through the
southern border and then in a in a wise
move
uh the governors of some of these states
Arizona Texas even Florida have just
decided to ship these people out sorry
we're not Sanctuary States we're not
Sanctuary cities you are we know this is
happening in Chicago uh O'Hare up north
uh it's happening as we just showed you
in Boston and uh who are these people
well here's a little video of just some
of the recent people wandering into the
United
States they let him through look at this
look at this look at
this
want to give all these women and
children what is going on here where are
the women where are the children can we
can we throw back to that find me a
woman or a child here find me a woman or
a child all these guys 18 19 20 25 they
look like they maybe not even in theirs
where are the women you see one woman
there you see one I mean it's absolutely
insane now you may remember last week we
showed you this video this this is just
incredible a guy goes up to a couple
illegals and he's trying to find out
some information from them and this guy
who has a middle eastern accent for
whatever that is worth basically
threatens him and there's subsequently a
little more information that it seems
like we may have found out about this
person but take a look at this by the
way if you are smart enough you would
know who I am but you are really not
smart enough to know who I am but soon
you're going to know who I am very easy
wow very easy the the entitlement the
entitlement no believe me I'm much
bitter than that the en
guys
wow that should send chills down your
spine if we were a serious country if
Joe Biden didn't have dementia if every
one of the people involved in this
administration were not incompetent
buffoons or intentionally negligent
morons uh we would be on a nationwide
manhunt for that guy who is that guy why
is how could you have the temerity to
walk into a country and then know you're
on camera and then threaten everybody uh
the N wokeness account who we uh we
quote a couple times
a week on this show uh this is this is
not confirmed this is just a question I
want to make that clear is this him mum
samadov leads the azerbajan Islamic
party they have close ties to Hezbollah
he was jailed for 12 plus years on
charges of attempts to organize Terror
attacks and overthrow the government he
was released on January 19th 2023 so it
does look like it potentially could be
him I don't know if it is but does our
government know if it is and if it is
him is that a problem and why is that
not on CNN that's the point so when you
listen to Elon Musk and he talks about
the Overton window what can we talk
about we have some guy who just wandered
into the country on top of the thousands
and thousands of other people who are
wandering in you don't know me you will
know me like do have we not learned
anything have we not learned anything as
I just mentioned two of the two of the
flights on 911 origin originated I think
it's two of the flights originated from
Boston Logan Airport was in New York
City during 911 what the is going
on here and we better get serious and we
better get serious real quick uh so of
course what what leads us to this now
bubbling into the mainstream is this
Supreme Court ruling that you know about
already Greg price tweeted about it
breaking the Supreme Court just ruled 5
to4 that the Biden Administration can
remove physical barriers Texas put up at
their border to stop The Invasion
Barrett and Roberts voted with the libs
now I want to show you video from
yesterday so this is
Joe Biden's National Security adviser
John Kirby who mostly spends his time
wearing suits that fit in a very very
strange way seems like he has a small
body big suit syndrome uh here he is
explaining that barbed wire doesn't work
uh they put barbed wire everywhere like
chicken CPS and jails and borders and
pretty much anywhere you wouldn't want
somebody but uh he knows that it doesn't
actually
work does razor wire
work does razor wire work for what does
it work for the border patrol to allow
them to have the access they need to be
able to uh to better process people that
are trying to get across the border I
don't think so and that's why we asked
for it to be removed what are you
talking about the the barbed wire the
razor wire it was put there so that
these people can't come in but what he's
saying is oh it doesn't work if you want
to let everybody in if you want to
process these people well then the
barbed wire is a problem now if you want
evidence that barbed wire works if
you're a serious nation and you want to
keep people out of your country uh
here's a little barbed wire over at the
Egypt Gaza border because Egypt for some
strange reason they don't want all their
Palestinian Brothers uh wandering into
sin well somebody better tell the
Egyptians that that doesn't work that
wall with all that wire think about all
of the money they've wasted on that wire
to keep Palestinians out of Egypt very
very bizarre but if you think John John
car John we'll get to John krey in a
minute but if you think that John Kirby
if you think that John Kirby small man
in big suit doesn't know what he's doing
here's diversity hire Karin Jean Pierre
explaining also that razor wire is
ineffective Texas is mean etc etc I
don't have the the specifics on the what
the border security is going to do and
how they're going to do it look we are
uh certainly glad that the Supreme Court
uh made the decision to to uh uh vacate
the injunction that prevented border
security to actually do their job to do
humanitarian work to actually uh to
actually uh enforce laws uh and it got
in the way it and what uh and what was
put forward that what what uh What uh
Texas was doing the governor was doing
was actually ineffective and that's
something that we have to remember it
was
ineffective they lie and lie and lie
they just lie about everything do catch
what she said there cuz again they every
now and again they accidentally tell you
what they really think she thinks it's
the job of border security to do
humanitarian work I'm fairly certain
that it's the job of border security to
secure the Border not to do humanitarian
work so then Texas comes in and says
this is our border you people seem to
think that your job is to do
humanitarian work even though you're
called border agents so we're going to
protect the border so now what has
happened here well yesterday uh Greg
Abbott he's just about had it he of
course is the Texas governor uh and he
has a statement uh on their
constitutional right to
self-defense uh we will why why don't I
read some of it to you how about that
the federal government has broken the
compact between the United States and
the states the executive branch of the
United States has a constitutional duty
to enforce federal laws protecting
States including immigration laws on the
book right now President Biden has
refused to enforce those laws and has
even violated them the result is that he
has smashed records for illegal
immigration despite having put been put
on notice in a series of letters one of
which I delivered to him by hand
President Biden has ignored Texas's
demand that he perform his
constitutional duties President Biden
has violated his oath to Faithfully
execute immigration laws enacted by
Congress instead of Prosecuting
immigrants for the federal crime of
illegal entry President Biden has sent
his lawyers into federal courts to sue
Texas for taking action to secure the
Border President Biden has instructed
his agencies to ignore Federal Federal
statutes that mandate the Detention of
illegal immigrants the effect is to
illegally allow their nmass parole into
the United States by wasting taxpayer
dollars to tear open Texas's border
security infrastructure President Biden
has enticed illegal immigrants away from
the 20 eight legal entry points along
this state's Southern border Bridges
where nobody drowns and into the
Dangerous Waters of the Rio Grande under
President Biden's Lawless border
policies more than 6 million illegal
immigrants have crossed into our
Southern Border in just three years that
is more than the population of 33
different states in this country this
illegal refusal to protect the states
has inflicted unprecedented harm on the
people across the United States James
Madison Alexander Hamilton and the other
Visionaries who wrote the US
Constitution foresaw that the states
should not be left to the mercy of a
lawless president who does nothing to
stop external threats like cartels
smuggling millions of illegal immigrants
across the border that is why the
framers included both article 14 wait is
that article no that's article four
sorry which promises that the federal
government shall protect each state
against Invasion article 10 Clause 3
which acknowledges the state's Sovereign
interests in prot protecting their
borders in Arizona versus the United
States with Scalia dissenting the
failure of The Descent the failure of
the Biden Administration to fulfill the
duties imposed by Article 4 has
triggered article 10 Clause 3 which
reserves this state the right of
self-defense for these reasons I have
already declared an invasion under
article 110 Clause 3 to invoke Texas's
constitutional authority to defend and
protect itself that Authority is the
supreme law of the land and supersedes
any federal statutes to the contrary the
Texas National Guard the Texas
Department of Public Safety and other
Texas Personnel are acting on that
Authority as well as state law to secure
the Texas border Greg Abbott governor of
Texas okay so we're going to dive a
little more into the legality of some of
this and I'm going to show you a video
that Ronda santis just put up uh just
this morning explaining a little bit of
the legality look I am not going to sit
here and tell you that I am a
constitutional lawyer does Amy Comey
Barrett have an argument does John
Roberts have an argument when they sided
with the Liberals on this I have no
doubt they have an argument uh but I
want to put aside legal Arguments for
just a moment and I just want to deal
with the reality on the ground and the
reality on the ground is that everyone
knows this country is being invaded and
everyone knows it is intentional right
let's let's just remember the reason
that this is happening is because Texas
decided to stop it from happening right
that's what happened Texas said we're
going to put up some of that barbed wire
and then the federal government was like
no no we don't like
barbed wire uh here's a little bit of
video of the Texas National Guard
actually being deployed at the
border those are good decent Americans
the members of the Texas National Guard
doing what is right for their state and
they are only doing it because for
months now the federal government has
not done anything about it actually the
federal government has gone out of its
way to make sure that as Greg Abbott
pointed out 6 million people in three
months uh sorry 6 million people in
three years do you realize how crazy
that is as he points out that's over the
population of 33 states that is
completely untenable that is how you
destroy a nation from the inside uh
here's a bit more of what the Texas
National Guard is doing right as we
speak right this very moment in Texas to
hold its line uh in its standoff with
the federal government you might note
barbed wire because apparently it
actually does
work
[Music]
you know I got nicked on barbed wire
once you guys ever get into a little
barbed wire ever happen to you I used to
go play basketball at this court that
was owned by like some company and a
bunch of us in high school used to play
at this court and we had to hop a fence
to get onto this court it was super nice
court and then eventually they put barb
wire there and I got my leg cut on Barb
I probably have a scar actually maybe
we'll show it to you tomorrow different
type of show but maybe we'll do that
because barbed wire works for example uh
these guys all work at my house every
day that's where we shoot the show uh
there's a code at the door that opens
the gate for them if I was to
disable that code and just put barbed
wire there instead would you find that
more difficult or easier to get in more
difficult that's why he gets paid yeah
you get it you guys get it uh here is
Governor Ronda santis who this morning
uh he's offering all of Florida's uh
support to Texas oh and by the way today
is National Florida day very exciting I
think we have an image for National
Florida day it involves an alligator
look at that that's that's basically how
Floridians feel uh at the moment so
happy Florida day to everybody uh but
govern santis did a great job now
remember he's a former lawyer clearly
the best governor in the country uh
this's about a two-minute video him just
clearly explaining the history what's
happening right now the legal issues the
Constitution the founders federalism
Etc Biden is going after Texas saying
that they must remove fortifications
from their border they put wire they put
things to keep people out uh Biden
saying you got to take that down to let
people come in illegally which is just
crazy and I remark that if the
Constitution was originally understood
to mean that a state could not protect
itself against an invasion that the
federal government could force a state
to allow an invasion the Constitution
would have never been ratified in the
first place Texas would have never
joined the union when it did uh and if
you look at Federalist 46 which uh
Daniel Horwitz pointed out uh James
Madison talks about uh situ situations
where Federal encroachment can be
mitigated uh by by state action so you
have Texas here uh that's holding its
ground they have every right to fortify
the Border Visa V an invasion and that's
Article 1 Section 10 of the Constitution
uh so so they're in the right you also
have a situation where liberal
jurisdictions over many many years have
been Sanctuary jurisdictions against
enforcing Federal immigration law so
you'll have somebody who's a Criminal
Alien they will not be given over to ice
and they will deliberately act to
frustrate the laws on the books and
somehow that's viewed as okay you have
Texas Who's acting to enforce the laws
on the books to ensure that they have a
secure State and that we have a secure
country uh so so all of this is just
nonsense what Biden's doing uh Texas has
every right to stand its ground we' in
Florida we've been sending people to
help uh for for many years now because
we understand it's not just the Texas
ISS issue it's ultimately an American
issue and if we don't have sovereignty
in this country uh then we're not going
to be a country anymore so so they have
every right to hold their ground uh to
stay stay the course and Florida will
continue to be there uh helping out
every step of the way all right so
that's just a calm clear explanation of
what's going on here and again the key
Point here is that the federal
government is not doing its job it is
not enforcing the laws on the books so
the states in this case Texas but I
think more of the red states are going
to start do this are going to start and
uh stepping in where the federal
government has decided to just leave not
only just leave help people get in it's
not it's not just like der elction of
Duty it's intentional destruction of the
country so I'm very glad to hear that
Ronda santis and unsurprised that he's
on the right side of this I'm glad to
hear that Florida is going to help Texas
as it can I have no doubt that some of
the other states are I saw that Kevin
stit up in Oklahoma uh he's standing by
uh Greg Abbott and many other Red State
Governor will right like the signal now
has been sent by disantis like red State
Governors get in on this it's a winning
issue and everyone knows uh that it's a
winning issue and really think about it
what what does the Constitution promise
US what is what is Living in America
what is the promise it's the promise of
life liberty in the pursuit of happiness
and if the federal government will not
ensure that you will be safe that we
will know who the citizens are that your
tax dollars will go to things that will
benefit you not benefit non-citizens etc
etc if they will not do that then they
are not abiding by that the the Civil
guarantee that we all have and once they
don't do that then we're all left so I
you know this is just the beginning to
me this seems like the fight of the year
now and it has been ramped up and and
it's going to get put on steroids as we
roll into this uh election year uh but
the states are all going to have to
decide what they're going to do you know
a place like Florida it's like we got
we're a peninsula we got three borders
of order so we have a coast guard and we
can do a pretty good job of making sure
that you know random boats don't don't
just show up which has happened all over
Europe right it's happened in Spain it's
happened in Italy it's happened in
Greece where the migrants just show up
we can do a pretty good job there but we
also have to decide what what are we
going to do on the ground right I always
joke about like we should just dig a
moat between us and Georgia and we'll
throw Gators in there but all the states
are going to have to decide what they're
going to do six million people in three
years you think they're all good guys
anyway one more let's go back to this
completely negligent Dei filled
ridiculous administ rtion here's Karen
jeanpierre one more time when asking if
old Joe could could we just get that
nice old man to show up to the
Border um Biden admitted Friday that the
border is insecure does he have any
plans to visit the southern border
before the president was in visited the
Border recently in January yeah that was
that was a year ago he's been there oh
he was there a year ago he was there a
year ago sure probably over a mill have
come in since then all hell's breaking
loose the state we're in a
constitutional crisis the states are
fighting the federal government he has
dementia like there's a bunch of
problems but he was there a year ago
does he remember he was there a year ago
probably not anyway this is just the
beginning of this and I have to say uh
obviously last week when Des sanus
dropped out uh I was not thrilled but it
was always and I think I said it on the
show several times it was always partly
like ringing around in my mind like the
states are the things that need to be
empowered maybe the whole federal system
is just too damn screwed up to to do
anything right at this point and I have
to say at this very moment uh on this
National Florida day I'm very glad that
Ronda santis is my Governor if you live
in Texas you should be very happy that
Greg Abbott is your governor and the
lines are being drawn right now and if
you are in a blue state or a blue City
and you're living in one of these
Sanctuary areas and you're watching the
crime get worse and the drugs get worse
and you're watching them fill up
homeless shelters with migrants and all
of these things you should probably
think about your life a little bit and
the choices that you have to make all
right let's get to a community q& a but
real quick let me talk to you guys about
Brock House Force Brick House Force
sorry not Brock that's Brock Brick House
Force guys it's a new year in men's
health survey a men's health survey ask
guys what would you change about
yourself guys said get fit look better
and improve intimacy these goals have
lined up with Force the nextg
testosterone booster all testosterone
products fail to build muscle and
enhance intimacy and performance it's
odd that I called it Brock that's weird
that's weird this study stud sorry they
studied the studied ingredients in force
have been shown to power up testosterone
for lean muscle weight loss and enhanced
intimacy but here's the kicker they
power up natural growth hormone and
that's the performance Difference Maker
force is total performance let's get you
started with 15% off and free Rush
shipping visit Brickhouse
for.com and enter booster that's b o o
SD that's promo code B stdr at
Brickhouse force.com Brickhouse
force.com statements have not been
evaluated by the Food and Drug
Administration that's probably a good
thing this product is not intended to
diagnose treat cure or prevent any
disease and it's not a substitute or
alternative for care from a healthcare
provider and now back to me all right
Ruben report.com
Community Q&A if you want to get a
question in right now you can jump on
locals we'll see if we can do something
on the Fly Mima says Dave have you
noticed that John kery looks like Herman
Monster no offense to Herman okay now I
get a Herman Monster reference obviously
the monsters were a little before my
time but they were in rerun so first we
have a John krey picture we just there's
John Carrey right there and there's yeah
the shape of the head the square shape
of the head the smile is kind of the
same the the brow like this now that is
true even the hair you could see how it
could happen with if John krey just
thinned it out a little bit but I have
always said that John Carrey looks more
like the tree guy from Lord of the Rings
that guy right there and he's an he's a
he's his name he's an ant and his name
is tree man tree beard so joh to me
that's what John krey looks more like I
don't know what they've injected him
with I'm sure it's biodegradable because
it's not like John krey would be a
hypocrite in any way whatsoever woody
woody I think not Phoenix roll with me
here what's next what's
next James says are cat 's legs as
picturesque in person uh or uh when you
or wait are they as pictur P picturesque
in person as they are when you see them
on television slash the small screen so
of course cat temped Greg gutfeld's uh
one of his Sidekicks on the Gutfeld
exclamation point program and there are
her legs I would say they're uh they're
representing the real leg that's what
her legs look like in real life you know
they say the what do they say the camera
adds 5 pounds uh and it all goes to the
legs no cat cats got nice legs the
people uh they love the legs and Fox
does like putting ladies on that show
off their leg Tyrus also shows off one
of his legs which
I can we get a picture of that is there
a way we could throw one of those on the
Fly I asked Tyrus so Tyrus you know he's
the other sidekick on GRE Gutfeld show
he's the was a former wrestler I guess
and he's this huge guy and I don't think
he likes me very much and he wears one
pant leg down and one pant leg up always
showing off one calf area of his leg and
I asked him about it once and he yelled
at me so I don't know what that's all
about but we'll see if we can get you a
picture do we have one Conor is working
on it we'll come back to this we'll get
you tyrus's leg I guess trigger warning
uh Lacy says how long do you think it
would have taken for the US to negotiate
the release of hostages in Palestine If
Britney Griner was held and how much
money do you think we would have forked
over for her conversely how long would
it have taken the Palestinians to do
Unthinkable things to her like murder
her for her way of life so of course
Britney Gyer former or no I guess she is
a current WNBA player there she is uh
who was arrested because she had a weed
pen and then she was held in a Russian
jail for quite some time uh look she
also happens to be a lesbian I think
like the gazin and Hamas would not have
been all too kind to her of course it
would have been escalated right they
still have American hostages now and you
know it's like these are American
citizens does anything work we talk
about the border the same thing does
anything work does any of does our
government care about us in any way and
it it's unfortunate that the conclusion
for many people is becoming no and
that's a damn shame I I look she is a
she is a black lesbian I suspect if a
black lesbian was being held in a in a
tunnel somewhere under Gaza uh that
would be being talked about every single
day as opposed to the people that are
held there right now and we would have
given up an awful lot uh Christine says
management of the view has decided it's
time to replace all the hosts and have
hired your team to find their
Replacements oh this is a thought
exercise I see what's happening here
they have to be diverse in their
opinions but not divisive gender is not
an issue Jordan Peterson has already
declined who do you hire and how many
well how many they have five of those
chicks on on The View right now you need
okay so all right so I'm gonna put
myself I'll moderate the thing so you
could I'll be whoopy I'll even wear her
clothes and put my hair up like that so
that's Dave ruin one all right so let's
get on the on the liberal side you're
going to put a Bill
Maher we can't use Peterson that's
interesting on the more conservative
side about
a a
Shapiro who who or Isabelle ah you know
what we're gonna go with Isabelle Brown
my co-host on people of the internet
she's young jeny she knows what's up and
it's good to have a chick involved so
we've got Dave billah Isabelle Brown
um we should throw these people A
diversity hire shouldn't we can we get a
uh we should bring on Karin Johan Pierre
just to dump on her the entire time no
no if I want it to be like
intellectually smart and people for to
really think uh think differently about
things um well all right so let's throw
another righty in I think you definitely
could throw a Shapiro on there and then
give me someone on the left that's not
completely bananas oh Tulsi that would
be pretty good that's a good show right
there how about me Bill Mah Isabelle
Brown Ben Shapiro and tulsey gabard like
that's a that's a that's an interesting
show of people from different walks of
life that have different opinions on
things there you've got different
genders you've got different sexualities
you've got different religions and those
aren't even the things that matter you
have different political ideas right
different different philosophic ideas
and these are all respectful people
wouldn't that be something this is the
day do we have uh do we have tyrus's leg
we can't find tyrus's leg wow it's not
on the internet tires his
legs this is the day says what is the
name of the adorable green plant on the
set each week yes I still want to know
because I want to get one I I assume are
you talking about this thing over here
so that it's actually a fake plant
because we don't have any windows in
here but it's a it's a fake plant of a
poos which we have tons of poos in our
house I love poos because they grow and
crawl just like that and if you you know
if you water them nicely a little bit of
sun like these things will they they
really want to live and they'll just
grow and grow and if you put them up
nice and high we have a a ledge on our
second floor in the house that we've got
a whole bunch of them just kind of
hanging down into the kitchen really
really beautiful that is that is a poos
if you're talking about my left and
right are always screwy with the camera
if you're talking about this guy what do
they call them it's similar to the poos
in the hanging thing that they'll keep
going it's also fake uh I think we used
to call them like Pearl plants or
something like that String of Pearls
yeah something like that and you can you
can definitely find those we have tons
and tons of uh plants live plants in the
house which I love taking care of and I
love doing landscaping and we're working
on a new Garden situation right now
which is being installed as we speak uh
we're going to have about like 15 by 40
foot beds like it's it's going to be
pretty massive and awesome and we're
going to start growing a ton of a ton of
new stuff um the Eurasian says what
famous people do you get compared to the
most often I think you kind of resemble
Steven dorf the bad guy in the first
blade film I have heard that before I
was going to say you look like a younger
version of him but it turns out he's
only a couple years older than you good
Lord I think he needs some of that genus
cell yes it does those skin creams will
take care of you um I get a couple
different things uh just the other day
the guy that was cutting my hair I went
to a new uh a new stylist and he said I
look like Matt
Damon that's pretty good that's pretty
good people always compare me to Denzel
Washington that's another one that I get
um no but sometimes sometimes I get if
I'm a if I I'm a little if I have like
five more pounds on me or if I'm like a
little bulkier uh um I used to get Brett
Favre a lot um yeah I used to get Brett
Favre what that's shocking to you I used
to get Brett Favre anyone else anyone
else anything else you can think of you
look like the pastor in Ozark I've been
told and Phoenix is telling me I look
like the pastor in Ozark I did not watch
Ozark so I don't know about that are we
trying to get an image perhaps yeah so
you know who knows who knows uh Florida
man Chuck says I know that talking about
politics and culture has been very
fulfilling for you and the team but what
is one thing or topic that you wish
would go away so that you would never
have to talk about it again Clinton
Trump January 6 BLM alphabet Mafia Co
cringe J here as a as a few examples for
me it's the LGBT thing the the alphabet
Mafia thing like once equality was there
you got to leave well enough alone and
so much of what's happened this this
transfer of a of a fight that I think
was just of equal rights um to a to this
new thing that has just burst forth and
just upended so much and and all of the
nonsense like I live in Florida we have
a family here life is good we go to the
we go to the Super Market we go to the
the local um we go everywhere like we go
to the petting zoo we go we wander
around like we're treated well we're not
nobody looks us looks at us in a weird
way like the world has moved on but the
activist class can't let things go so
they want the gays to think they're
oppressed and they want the blacks to
think they're oppressed and women to
think they're oppressed and it's like so
like if we could just let go of it
remember that video what was that video
it was um it was Morgan Freeman I think
talking to Don Lemon years ago on CNN
and lemon's like what can we do about
racism and Morgan Freeman's like stop
talking about
it lemon's head explodes but it's the
same thing with the LGBT Mafia it's like
let go of this stop trying to
sexualize kids and everything else let
people live normal lives like my life
might seem like a little crazy like like
I'm somebody that talks to a camera for
a living and I guess people know who I
am and whatever but my life in terms of
what goes on in my house making meals
being with the kids taking walks like
watching movies it's it's a normal life
as normal as everyone else is um but if
you just keep talking about all of the
differences we will never get over any
of that stuff Margaret says hey Dave do
you think Trump is doing so well because
he is essentially an incumbent or
because he is truly a better choice than
all the other candidates well I think
the reason he's doing so well is because
of the rocket fuel of all of the
insanity right Trump is viewed by x
amount of people as the antidote to the
insanity what what put Trump on the map
in the first place I'm going to build a
wall and Mexico is going to pay for it
now he subsequently didn't build much of
a wall and he now admits that Mexico is
never going to pay for it but when you
see all of the Border stuff now a huge
percentage of people think Trump is the
is the solution to the problem they now
view Biden as the problem and Trump as a
solution I have no doubt Trump will be a
gajillion time this would not be
happening under Trump for sure so the
rocket fuel behind Trump I don't know
it's that I don't I really don't think
it's the incumbent thing I think our our
our memories are so shoddy now that most
people aren't thinking back to preco
presidency of trump which which really
was cooking right like the economy was
doing well we largely had peace we were
talking to North Korea the Abraham
Accords lowest all-time black
unemployment I don't think that's really
what's driving the Trump thing right now
what's driving the Trump thing is he's
perceived to be a victim of the system
which to some extent he is and they're
trying to take him off ballots and
they're going with these court cases and
he's been right about the large issues
now it doesn't mean that granularly if
he was president again he would be able
to fix all of the issues like when we
showed you that video just 10 minutes
ago of Ronda santis like clearly
explaining what the Federalist Papers
meant and what the founders intended and
the difference between State's rights
and federal government like I don't
think he can really do all of that but
he has a good directional feel for all
of those things and I think people see
that and they see that as sign
significantly better than the guy who
has dementia who's being driven by
Communists Tony says uh when is our next
Community Meetup I've been saving for it
we've been discussing it and we will get
back to you on that we have not done a
community Meetup in in uh actually since
July Jesus all right we owe you guys a
community Meetup uh we will do it
somewhere somewhere in Florida we did
the last one in Miami it was right on
the on the water over there was totally
it was a great time uh we will make
something happen uh maybe maybe we'll do
the other coast maybe we'll do the
Southwest Coast of Florida that that
could be nice uh cam says Dave if you
had the opportunity to speak to Trump
about what you believe he should focus
on that would resonate with the
undecided lefties what would that be um
I think it would be it wouldn't be an
issue specifically it would be it would
be a tonal thing and I know it's hard to
you can't tell Trump to do anything and
one of my Arguments for Trump over the
years was that all of the people that
were always like the Mean Tweets you got
to ease up in the Mean Tweets it's hard
to tell the guy that did the thing that
nobody thought anyone could do it's hard
to tell him how to behave right so I
everything I say right now I say with a
grain of salt but I know that there are
a huge because we all know these people
you know these people in your life there
are a huge amount of people mostly women
and it who have an aversion to Trump and
you could say it's because of grab him
by the or this or the how he talks
about women or whatever if Trump wants
to bring in the disaffected libs and
again though especially since October
7th but now with the border the John
fedman types the Bill Mar types I get
maybe those guys are never going to vote
Republican but people who have a similar
mindset you want to get those he's got
to figure out a way to tone down some of
the stuff so two days ago after when he
was doing his acceptance speech or his
winning speech after uh after New
Hampshire when he he was like making fun
of what Nikki Haley wore and to me it
was like all right we've been through
this before I'm not saying it's the
worst thing in the world I don't have
Trump to rangement syndrome or anything
else but I know that there is a certain
set of especially Suburban women
probably in their 30s to 60s who just
watch him and they might be like man the
Democrats are nuts and they're racist
and they don't want my kids to have a
job cuz they're white and everything
else but this guy's just a dick and they
don't want that so I would want to have
some conversation around that maybe I
don't know that it would work it
probably wouldn't but I think that that
would be good advice for him uh
Elizabeth says any plans to have David
interview you again I love those but I
know he's not a huge fan of being on the
camera yeah he doesn't want to be on the
camera he has no social media at this
point you know taking care of the kids
he's making sure that uh you know I get
haircuts when I'm supposed to and I'm
fed and everything else and he I I don't
maybe like I'm not giving you a hard no
on that but we haven't really discussed
it and I don't think that's that's what
what he wants and actually I think it's
very refreshing when you're around
someone that doesn't want to be on
camera or who doesn't want to be on
social media or any of those things and
they're just functioning in the real
world it's uh it's pretty good Joe says
I've been hearing a lot about this
country's loneliness epidemic let's say
for the sake of discussion there is one
what steps should people take to
overcome something like this well look
that's the ultimate irony that actually
connects us to the previous question
it's the ultimate irony of social media
we all thought it was going to make us
more social and it made us less social
in a lot of ways right we we don't just
go I've talked about this many times
like I used to back in the day when I
lived in New York City I used to just
like going to a bar and sitting down and
talking to the bartender or talking to
the people at the bar I've made lifelong
friends that way just chatting with
someone who might be in town that you're
never going to see again you know like
we we are social creatures and we
thought that we were all going to be
handed this thing and it was going to
connect us to the world and we would all
feel that innate connection but we now
know that that has blown apart so much
of our connections we're distracted our
our attention spans aren't right um I
can tell you from interviewing people
over the last 10 years I've seen
people's attention spans just be blown
apart or train of thought be blown apart
where I'm interviewing somebody and I
can see they're losing what they're
saying in the midst of it right and that
didn't happen as often as as it did
maybe 10 years ago like we know that
that this thing in the endless scrolling
and that we've we've atomized everything
that you used to maybe go to a bar with
some friends to pick up a chick or pick
up a dude and just randomly go up to
somebody and you had to have a line to
go up and say something to them but now
we've atomized it all into oh this
person look I have all their all of
their pictures already and I know
exactly what movies they like and what
foods they like to eat like we've taken
the the the mystery out of romance and
and the Mystery out of life and we're
going to all it's the great challenge
for all of us as human beings to figure
out it's this thing is not evil it is a
tool and like a hammer a hammer can help
you nail in a nail to help you build
your home or a hammer you can whack
somebody in the head with it and kill
them it's up to you what what you decide
to do with it and and that's the
challenge for everybody but they're
definitely is an epidemic of loneliness
and and um Neurosis I saw that something
like 10% of Americans are now on uh
prescription drugs so whether that's
Aderall or all of that other stuff right
every commercial that you turn on
anti-depressants every commercial
there's a cloud a cartoon cloud and it's
following a guy and then he takes the
pill and the cloud goes away but then he
realizes he has to take eight other
pills and then he has restless leg
syndrome and then the side effects
include diarrhea nausea vomiting and
it's like I'm really depressed so so
we've got to figure out a way to deal
with some of this stuff better I it's
why I try not to spend any time on this
thing on the weekends except on locals
showing you guys food and what music I'm
listening to that kind of stuff and it's
why I do Off the Grid August Eddie says
what are the chances that Trump ever
admits his missteps I like you voted for
Trump will support him now however his
inability to show anyone non-abrasive
temperament will cost us votes in 24
well I think that sort of gets to what I
was talking about with the with the
women before like a little bit of hum
humility on his part would be good I
think the issue there also it's not just
that he's not really wired for that it's
also that the base doesn't demand it of
him and he's very attached to what the
Bas wants so the Bas so think about it
this way the Bas hates operation warp
speed right because they hate the vaxes
and they didn't want the mandates and
any of those things and he didn't
mandate that anyone do it but the the
base of the Republican party or the Maga
thing is the most antix whatever he has
shown no remorse in any of that yet it
didn't cost him politically the base
seems to love him more than ever so the
problem is his selective pressures are
not uh are not pushed in a way that
would allow him to have a mayaula right
so that's kind of how it goes oh you
know what I'm on Newsmax in a couple
minutes so we got to go fast here all
right doc says after watching Joy Reed
support books on pedophilia in
elementary schools the question that
came to me was this why are there books
like that targeted towards six to n
yearolds who intentionally does that
that what does that say about the moral
state of education entertainment and
Publishing I wish I had more time to
answer that question but the marxists
and the Communists they are here to
destroy everything and if you can
destroy a six or eight- year-old's brain
by confusing them about gender or
sexuality or racism make they make them
think that they're guilty because of
something they didn't do or that they're
not in the body that they're supposed to
be and and blow themart and every which
way I can hear Newsmax calling me right
now if you can if you can do all of that
to a bunch of kids then that you are
primed to have them live like slaves for
the rest of their life on that note I
will be on Newsmax John Bachman in just
a moment uh so apologies there's no
postgame show today uh and everybody
else we will see you tomorrow I tell
every young man is telling me I'm
thinking of getting married or somebody
I said look you have any advice I said
yeah pick a family with five sisters or
more and he looked at me what the hell
is that all about I said it's really
simple that way one of them always loves
you not the same
one you always have somebody on your
side